[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo l'essentiel les temps
forts de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec mickaël vallet vosges
au qatar bonjour à tous est notre invité
cette semaine tu es martin autant
bonjour mon genre but est de la france
est soumise de seine saint denis on va
revoir avec vous bien évidemment les
temps forts de la semaine avec la
polémique et or sur le budget 2010 8 et
notamment sur l' isf la loi
antiterroriste le premier texte de la
session voté à l'assemblée nationale
et puis la réélection de gérard larcher
à la présidence du sénat mais d'abord on
va commencer par la bataille du budget
qui est lancé à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement défend un projet de loi
de finances équilibrées mais certains
dénoncent un budget pour les riches au
coeur de la polémique la réforme de la
sf qui crée le malaise au sein même de
la majorité
pour éviter que la polémique enfle dans
son propre camp le premier ministre est
venu parler budget avec les députés en
marche certains élus de la majorité ne
sont pas d'accord avec la réforme de
l'isf f et le font savoir
c'est le rapporteur général du budget
joël giraud qui a ouvert le débat la
semaine dernière les yachts les jets
privés les chevaux de course
les voitures de luxe ou encore les
lingots d'or ne sont plus prises en
compte dans le nouvel impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
ce n'est pas possible le porte parole du
gouvernement minimise rien d'anormal
c'est la logique du travail
parlementaire
il est normal que l'exécutif puisse
aussi accepter des corrections quand
elles sont jugées nécessaires
il s'agit sur le sujet évoqué non pas de
dénaturer la transformation de l' isf
est un impôt qui est concentré sur la
question immobilière pour relancer
l'économie et finances et l'économie
réelle mais il ya certaines choses qui
peuvent être corrigés donc nous ont
toute confiance aux parlementaires pour
faire des positions qui vont dans ce
sens là
et pourtant même à bercy les deux
ministres ne semble pas toujours sur la
même ligne ce week end presque au même
moment
bruno le maire affirme qu'il est contre
toute nouvelle taxation sur le luxe
gérald darmanin plaide lui pour une
taxation des produits ostentatoire le
débat sur l' isf agite donc l'exécutif
comme le groupe en marche mais rien à
voir avec les dissensions de l'ère
hollande comme l'expliquent un ancien
député socialiste ya une cohérence
il ya une cohésion totale du groupe
parlementaire derrière le gouvernement
le président la république
honnêtement j'ai connu dans des mandats
précédents des budgets qui faisait
l'objet de critiques et qui paiera très
forte en interne un bâtiment pas le cas
les députés pourront amender le budget
dès la semaine prochaine le projet de
loi de finances 2010 8 arrive en
commission mercredi
alors justement que l'on y noter votre
groupe la france insoumise et très
mobilisés depuis le début de la
législature est ce que vous êtes prêt à
mener la bataille du budget vous avez
déposé des amendements et convient on
un chiffre astronomique vous pouvez
comptez vous pouvez compter sur nous
nous serons très mobilisés dans cette
bataille et nous allons proposer un
contre budget donc c'est vous dire si
nous allons être offensifs sur ce
terrain par vos collègues socialistes
triompher cette semaine sans doute pas
le même parce que celui que nous
apercevant de nos collègues socialistes
ressemble d'une certaine manière au
budget de l'ère hollande nous nous
voulons une nouvelle ère du point de vue
de l'organisation du budget et ce que
nous contestons et ce qui nous révolte
même dans ce qui est présenté
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe et la logique des
manuels macron c'est qu'au fond la rue
distribution se fait au profit des plus
riches parce que il y a en gros 5
milliards d'euros revu vos le budget des
plus riches ou budget dérisoire
on entend depuis mais il faut être
concret pourquoi parce qu'il ya d'un
côté 5 milliards d'euros mais non c'est
pas fait s'il s'est passé
non c'est pas facile notamment pour ceux
qui vont subir ce qui ce qui risque
d'être décidée non 5 milliards d'euros
pour les plus riches par le biais de la
réforme de liesse ai fait d'autres
niches fiscales qui vont être favorisée
et de l'autre côté des prestations
sociales pour le grand nombre qui vont
elles être miné et donc 5 euros en moins
d'appels on le sait la csg pour
l'épauler retraités qui va augmenter
donc c'est ce sont des mesures très
concrètes qui concerne aussi la santé
puisque vous savez que le tarif
hospitalier le forfait hospitalier va
augmenter lui aussi de deux euros donc
je vais pas faire toute la liste mais si
vous voulez au final et à robin des bois
à l'envers qui est aujourd'hui à la tête
de l'état est ce que vous pensez que le
groupe majoritaire à public en marge va
voter ce budget en tout cas va être là
et voter les mesures comme un seul homme
alors qu'il peut y avoir un début de
fronde y compris au sein de la majorité
qu'est ce que vous sentez à je ressens
que dans la majorité il ya des moments
où ça coince c'est évident et là on le
voit sur les yachts sur la partie la
plus je dirais impopulaire des mesures
c'est incompréhensible que d'exclure les
livres autres les jets de la saison
moment même on nous explique qu'il faut
contraindre les budgets publics
c'est honteux vous dites c'est honteux
donc un certain nombre de deux pieds
députés qui peut-être juste se sont
promenés dans leur circonscription a
rencontré des habitants qui leur ont dit
écoutez c'est indécent peut-être qu'il
va y avoir une petite
à la marge quelques amendements
favorables mais ça ne change pas la
logique est pour l'instant en effet au
gouvernement
le gouvernement a une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale pour voter ce but
et mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait une
majorité social une majorité d'idées
dans le pays pour mener une telle
politique est une politique de deux
voilà que deux classes justement parce
que moi je vous parlais du pays en effet
il ya des manifestations qui vont avoir
lieu la semaine prochaine le 10 mai
manifestation coding unitaire autres cas
les partis politiques les syndicats
jean luc mélenchon avait dit lors de
cette manifestation d'une manifestation
qu'il ferait plier emmanuel macron le
peut-il encore nous nous le souhaitons
et nous essayons de tout mettre en avant
lundi je jure de le faire on doit dire
que nous allons tout faire pour en effet
empêché cette politique est une
politique de continuité par rapport à
l'ère sarkozy et l'ère hollande dans
c'est logique profonde mais
d'accélération aussi d'une certaine
manière un de la contrainte budgétaire
on a vu suppression des emplois aider à
vous avez toute une série de mesures qui
vont rendre plus difficile la vie pour
la majorité des français est plus facile
la vie pour les plus riches les 1% les
plus riches si vous attendez des
manifestations de la semaine prochaine
qu'elle soit massive
j'attends aussi une convergence j'ai
noté que force ouvrière avait changé de
position et s'attelait maintenant à
combattre la loi travail ce qui est une
excellente nouvelle et jean luc
mélenchon a dit que nous souhaitions
être maintenant derrière les syndicats
donc ce qu'il faut c'est bien organisé
le rythme des mobilisations et
convaincre toujours plus pour faire
plier le gouvernement sur la loi travail
qui n'est pas encore passée au parlement
les camps bien même le serait-elle on
peut encore faire reculer le
gouvernement et par ailleurs c'est vrai
que nous on met dans la balance
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre déjà en trois
mois assez important qui leur est un
nouvel assaut hivernal de la france est
soumise à manifester comme il y avait eu
au mois de septembre
ce que nous cherchons aujourd'hui ce
sont les convergences 1 avec avec le
gars avec d'autres coureurs propres
initiales de la france est soumise non
nous l'avons fait et maintenant nous
cherchons la convergence aussi peut-être
avec avec vos collègues communistes
parce qu'on sent bien sur certains sur
certains points notamment sur cette
bataille budgétaire qui s'annonce vous
pourriez faire cause commune où est ce
que vous êtes prêts si vous écoutez les
débat à l'assemblée on les écoute matin
je croie en ce qu'il ne vous aura pas
échappé que bien souvent nous nous
applaudissons les uns les autres et nous
racontons des choses extrêmement srec
co2 chez steam ça ne paraît budgétaire
j'estime que oui nous allons aller dans
le même sens c'est l'évidence même
et de ce point de vue il ya une
convergence de fait l'idée pour
combattre ce gouvernement des riches
voient passer un autre texte qui a
marqué cette semaine notamment à
l'assemblée nationale c'est le projet de
loi antiterroriste qui a été voté vous
savez certainement ce texte est destiné
à faire sortir de l'état d'urgence il a
été approuvée mais pas l'unanimité
regardez c'est le reportage de rami cas
415 voix contre 127
sans surprise l'assemblée nationale a
largement voté le projet de loi
antiterroriste qui vise à intégrer dans
le droit comment certains dispositifs de
l'état d'urgence le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est félicité de cette
victoire
on voit bien que contre les terroristes
faut la foi se protéger et en même temps
garder ce qui fait la valeur de notre
patrie ces valeurs de justice de liberté
qui sont au coeur finalement du système
que les terroristes nous adversaires de
doges voudrait détruire car oui
aujourd'hui je suis content je crois que
ce texte va permettre de protéger les
français
pourtant le front national et les
républicains crient au laxisme tous
leurs amendements visant à durcir le
texte presque tous ont été rejetés
je suis convaincu que le gouvernement
sera obligé de venir progressivement
vers nos propositions et je crains
malheureusement qu'il soit obligé de
remettre 1
pour anne application l'état d'urgence
il est temps que ce gouvernement arrête
de faire joujou arrête de faire de la
communication retire son projet de loi
qui est dérisoire et ridicule et
s'attaque véritablement a proposé à la
représentation nationale
un grand projet de lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste
sur ce texte le débat s'est polarisé
entre la gauche et la droite les
communistes et la france est soumise ne
cesse de dénoncer un texte inutile et
liberticide
on a enfreint l'état de droit'' manière
grave puisque l'état d'urgence de viaduc
ou permanents et en plus sensible des
populations je pense notamment aux
réfugiés qui n'ont aucun rapport avec le
terrorisme et à qui on va faire subir un
sort en dehors de tout là aussi de toute
légalité conquête nationale dont c'est
un vrai problème
prochaine étape une commission mixte
paritaire où il faudra trouver un
compromis entre la version du sénat et
celle de l'assemblée l'état d'urgence
s'achèvera le 1er novembre
deux ans après sa mise en oeuvre à la
suite des attentats terroristes du 13
novembre 2015 et j'ai vu cette semaine
encore ces actions terroristes
pourquoi inutile alors que certains même
dans l'opposition je pense à la droite
disent qu'il ne faut pas sortir de
l'état d'urgence oui la vérité l'autre
cela parce que les dispositions de
l'état d'urgence ne sont pas de nature à
être efficace pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
aujourd'hui contre ces actes terroristes
qu'il faut évidemment anéanti faire en
sorte de protéger les français on est
dans cet état d'esprit
mais là on se trouve face à un texte qui
va laminer les droits et les libertés
dans ce pays c'est pas simplement moi
qu'ils disent pas simplement la france
insoumise
c'est également expert de menus qui ont
dit que ce texte était une menace grave
pour les droits en france donc il ne
sert à rien de durcir le les contrôles
d'identité de faire en sorte que les
perquisitions se fasse en dehors de
toute logique du droit commun français
aucune action contre le terrorisme mais
bien sûr une action est ce que l'on
aurait l'eau que je vais vous dire
maj venir à bout sur ce texte aboutir à
rien et par exemple je vous prends deux
exemples en france on n'a que douze
juges antiterroristes c'est tout donc
mettons des moyens faisons en sorte que
la justice le renseignement aient les
moyens de lutter ça c'est concret et ça
c'est vous dites y'a rien dans le texte
de l'autre on a un mental de déposer des
amendements qui permettent justement de
déployer des moyens humains et
financiers pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
moi je me bats par exemple pour des
cellules d écoute parce que je pense que
un certain nombre de familles qui voient
un proche en train de 2,2 de dériver
vers des filières jihadistes il faut
qu'elle puisse parler qu'elle ait des
lieux qu'elle soit que voyez que la
société puisse se protéger concrètement
tout cela ne peuvent pas rentrer dans la
loi qui nous a été dit ce que vous nous
donnez tout cas elle est inefficace
regardez notre amendement sur lafarge
quand on a une entreprise qui quand même
donne de l'argent sur des filières on se
réalimente le djihadisme et que le
gouvernement refuse de s'y atteler
refusent de s'y atteler et de combattre
ce qui est quand même le nerf de la
guerre l'argent
bon moi je dis que cette loi est une loi
d'affichage dangereuses pour nos
libertés publiques comme le disent les
experts de l'onu et donc inefficace à
nous protéger tous un bien rien dans ce
texte si certains soulignent certains
sur les prisons dont on sait que c'est
l'un des hauts lieux de l'incubateur de
la radicalisation ce que pour vous ces
lacunes graves
oui c'est déjà de lacunes mais il y en a
une deuxième aussi ce sont les moyens
donnés à la psychiatrie en france parce
qu'on a vu certains cas qui relevait de
la psychiatrie parmi ceux qui ont commis
des actes terroristes
donc bien sûr qu'il faut prendre en
considération l'ensemble du che pas
comment dire mais du maillage social
français pourrait essayer par tous de se
donner les moyens les moyens humains et
financiers de démanteler les réseaux et
de prévenir autant faire ce peuple parce
que le risque zéro n'existe pas et nous
le savons tous prévenir autant faire se
peut ce type d'actes clémentine autain
jour amène un petit peu sur le côté
parlementaire si on comprend bien ce que
vous me dites depuis le tailleur sur un
texte qui aurait mérité une forme
d'unanimité
il est impossible la majorité ne
l'écoutent pas suffisamment l'opposition
et vous même
vous avez fait des propositions le ps a
fait des propositions et amendements ont
été rejetés
donc cette majorité ne m'écoute pas
l'opposition ce désaccord avec
l'opposition c'est qu'on n'a pas la même
vision de la protège vous voyez quand
nous on met l'accent contre lafarge et
pour des moyens pour la justice pour et
vous auriez vous faire vous auriez mais
pour la bêtise et les filières de rang
sur le fait que cette importance là et
les filières de renseignement parce que
le renseignement c'est quand même un des
nerfs de la guerre très très très
important un très important
donc nous on met l'accent sur ça le
gouvernement pense qu'il faut des lois
d'affichage pour fliquer tout le monde
du matin au soir
nous nous estimons ça c'est inefficace
et attentatoire aux libertés
par exemple je vous donne un exemple sur
le contrôle au faciès sur contrôle
d'identité qui vont déferler en france
maintenant est autorisé à tout bout de
champ les pales caméramans oui mais la
sainte mais pas simplement nous avons
déposé un amendement pour le récépissé
mots le récépissé
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des contrôles
au faciès et que cette loi va augmenter
la possibilité de recours aux contrôles
au faciès et notre amendement sur le
récépissé n'a pas été acceptée donc nous
on veut des mesures efficaces mais qui
ne se retourne pas vers des personnes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les acteurs
russes et cette semaine clémentine
autain le sénat oui c'était aussi
l'information de la semaine a eu son
président
c'est donc que gérard larcher qui a été
reconduit facilement au plateau
troisième mandat de trois ans jérôme
bonnard très applaudi gérard larcher est
donc élu une troisième fois président de
la haute assemblée
merci à tous celles et ceux qui m'ont
accordé très largement leur confiance
dans leur diversité
le sénat devra incarner par sa
composition
l' équilibre territorial et la diversité
qui cimente une nation
quelques heures avant le vote son ancien
adversaire aux précédentes élections il
ya trois ans jean pierre raffarin
voyez d'ailleurs en lui un homme
incontournable dans le nouveau paysage
politique français et je pense que
gérard lâchait va pouvoir avoir un rôle
particulier dans les instances de la
république
il va être le plus expérimenté du
dispositif donc il va avoir la sagesse
qu'il convient pour cette situation
gérard larcher l'insubmersible beaucoup
lui trouve aujourd'hui de l'empathie que
ce soit de l'opposition la plus à gauche
jusqu'aux représentants du gouvernement
on sait aussi un homme qui respecte
l'institution ici au sénat est qui et
qui écoute en tout cas l'eau
les propositions qu'on va faire les
groupes chaque maintenant vient le temps
du travail je ne veux pas que la sagesse
du sénat lui permettent d'apprécier
l'effort du gouvernement le respect et
la proposition de confiance avec les
collectivités locales
à 68 ans gérard larcher le champion du
compromis
élu pour la première fois en 1986 a su
asseoir sa domination du haut du plateau
du palais du luxembourg dont il connaît
toutes les arcanes et les subtilités
clémentine autain que représente pour
vous un gérard larcher lesage élément de
stabilité au contraire le perturbateur
le président d'un sénat qui est bien à
droite et donc je dirais que la partie
de réélection qui donne aujourd'hui les
équilibres enfin les minimes où les
déséquilibres comme un souverain du
sénat montrent que c'est l'image et la
photographie du monde d'avant ces accès
issus de déséquilibre politique des
rapports de force politiques de des
municipales donc on est face à un sénat
qui ne ressemble pas tellement à la
photographie politique aujourd'hui qui
est bouleversé on le voit on l'a vu à
l'occasion de la présidentielle et des
législatives est par ailleurs moi je
pense que il souhaite être garant de
cette institution qu'est le sénat et
nous nous voulons une nouvelle
république
la 6ème république et que de ce point de
vue le sénat ne nous paraît pas être
l'institution je vous faites du sénat
dans la 6ème république
je me suis pris mais oui je pense qu'il
faut deux chambres si deux chambres
c'est possible bien sûr mais les deux
chambres peuvent être avec tout même
rôle avec le même nom avec des allers
retours je suis pas forcément opposé au
fait qu'ils aient deux chambres mais ça
mériterait de longs débats mais en tout
cas je ne ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui le
sénat dans la façon dont il est désigné
soit un atout pour le dynamisme
démocratique de notre pays je le crois
pas géant larcher on a fait si vous
voulez la chambre qui défendent les
territoires et s'est constitué un petit
peu comme cela vous n'êtes pas quand
vous faites un peu l'amour pourquoi pas
un député qui était lui d'un territoire
défend aussi son territoire
l'assemblée comme le smac de fond de
territoire free alors par contre ce qui
m'inquiète c'est quand je vois le projet
du gouvernement
qui veut faire en sorte que les
circonscriptions des législatives soit
en gros le double de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui ça va pas aider à rapprocher
les citoyens de leurs élus et à défendre
correctement des territoires à
l'assemblée nationale justement vous
craignez ce qu'on appelle le redécoupage
de la carte électorale pour ceux qui
connaissent vraiment mais on va re
découper un peu les circonscriptions ça
c'est une le projet 40 est emmanuel
macron est un projet hyper
technocratique qui vise tout simplement
à la mine et le rôle des parlementaires
d'ailleurs je trouve qu'un petit parfum
antiparlementaire qui se dégage dans ce
pays et en particulier de la part de
cette majorité gouvernementale
et oui je le conteste pas ce que je
pense qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie sans
représentant du peuple
aujourd'hui en tout cas un prêt
peut-être dans une démocratie active
plus grande mais et ses élus ils doivent
pas être ils ne doivent pas être moins
nombreux mais à mon avis peut être plus
nombreux pour justement être mieux à
même de faire leur travail dans des
conditions correctes
on va maintenant retrouver notre
partenaire du figaro
[Musique]
bonjour amical katia bonjour clémentine
autain revient sur la polémique de la
semaine c'était jeudi il y en avait
plusieurs semaines y en a une force
c'était jeudi s'en est pris à ceux qui
foutent le bordel chez gm s
libération titre son quotidien du jour
macron le fils caché de sarkozy est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
comparaison
oui d'ailleurs il mène une politique
dont nicolas sarkozy aurait pu rêver
hein parce que la réforme de l'isf il en
a rêvé il n'a même pas osé la faire et
voilà emmanuel macron qu'il l'a fait ce
qui est frappant c'est le degré de
mépris de classe qui se dégage dans des
petites phrases pas totalement maîtrisée
par le crif bien sûr moi j'appelle ça du
mépris de classe les fainéants les
cyniques les rien ce qui ne sent rien
vous rendez compte
et maintenant voilà des salariés qui se
mobilisent pour leur travail en plus
donc tous ceux qui l'écoutent imprécis
les propos mais c'est dangereux parce
que la grève la mobilisation sociale
elle
ça fait partie des droits
constitutionnels donc il ne faut pas les
mépriser
il faut au contraire les entendre et les
comprendre la démocratie oui elle se
fait aussi dans la rue oui elle se fait
aussi au travers de la grève et de
mobilisation sociale et par ailleurs les
salariés de gm s ils veulent travailler
et vous aimez en france des millions de
français qui sont au chômage qui ne
demande qu'une chose c'est à travailler
or si les politiques publiques ne
permettent pas de partager le temps de
travail de partager les richesses de
favoriser l'investissement public pour
justement relancé par l'activité notre
économie alors en effet le chômage de
masse va s'inscrire ou alors il va être
transformée comme en allemagne par
l'essor de travailleurs pauvres c'est
pas la société une autre polémique de la
semaine justement vous le disiez en a eu
plusieurs
vous avez cosigné cette semaine un
amendement pour obtenir le retrait du
drapeau européen dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée une initiative qui a été
saluée par plusieurs cadres du front
national vous vous retrouvez sur cette
question là non je me dis franchement
non on ne se retrouve pas sur lui non on
ne se retrouve pas cette question là
pour une raison assez simple moi je suis
profondément européenne et parce que je
suis profondément européenne j'estime
que l'union européenne et ses politiques
actuelles qui vise à faire un
gigantesque concurrence entre les
peuples
ea ne certainement pas tirer vers le
haut les droits les protections bon ça
c'est une europe qui va dans le mur avec
ses traités néolibéraux et son
fonctionnement qui n'est pas commun pour
la musique ou dans les dossiers qui
n'est pas très démocratique donc voilà
donc une mauvaise humeur que nous
exprimons au moment où on voulait le
remplacer par l'onu n'ont pas comment le
front national seraient d'accord avec ça
parce que par exemple aux nues avec ces
experts qui conteste la loi liberticide
eux contre le contre le terrorisme je ne
vois pas que le front national soit
d'accord avec cet ensemble international
le front national est victime et le
front national lui ce qu'il souhaite
c'est un repli identitaire avec une
france éternelle c'est pas notre projet
c'est pas nos projets mais nous disons
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une question de
souveraineté et je prends toujours
l'exemple du ceta qui est un traité de
libre-échange que qui n'est pas se
gagner au vote du parlement pour
l'instant mais qui est déjà entrée en
vigueur et le par le parlement français
avait rejeté le ceta mais comme à
l'échelle européenne
il est accepté alors la souveraineté
nationale est complètement mise à terre
donc c'est une double mauvaise humeur
voyez entre eux n'a pas été axé affaire
close non mais je veux dire pour moi
c'est pas la mère des batailles
franchement cette affaire de symbolique
oui d'autant qu'en plus le drapeau on
pourrait discuter vous savez que les
étoiles n'y a pas tous les pays qui sont
aujourd'hui dans l'union européenne ce
drapeau était installé sous l'ère
hollande c'est ma une vieille affaire
qu'il soit là bon je suis pas pour jouer
sur les les c'est un symbole mais c'est
pas c'est pas la mère des batailles en
revanche la question de qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans le cadre de cette union
européenne qui marche sur la tête
comment peut on retrouver la population
que nous souhaitons donner tg la
polémique encore cette semaine autour
demande de la france ont soumis sur la
question de l'islam radical
la dernière en date concerne la
communiste alors que la france soumise
du coup sony amour qui a qualifié le
terrorisme de marseille de martyrs elle
a été soutenue par la suppléante de
françois ruffin qui s'appelle zoé des
bureaux jean luc mélenchon a dû se
réagir et se désolidarise
et j'ai partagé l'été s'en serait bien
passé commande de ces polémiques là jean
luc mélenchon oui bien sûr mais voilà il
a mis les points sur les i n'entretenons
pas non plus ambiguïté sur voilà sur sur
une phrase qu'elle a dit que je ne
partage pas ça vient en tout cas
relancer le procès en islam au gauchisme
je le mets entre guillemets ce mot qui
vous qui vous et vous personnellement
qu'elle fait c'est bien sûr et vous
savez ce qu'est l'île annuel match
oui oui vous savez ce qu'il a dit sur
france inter qui m'a mis dans une colère
vraiment noir il a dit clémentine autain
texto à nouer des accords avec les
frères musulmans
voilà donc entendu on n'est pas non mais
c'est n'importe quoi
aucune idée à craquer frères musulmans
franchement je vais penser vous auriez
fait un groupe international
mais d'où d'où vient cette histoire
quels sont les faits au delà qu'est ce
que c'est que ce terme vous savez que
dans les années 30 ont traité les
communistes de judéo bolchevisme c'est
quoi qu'elle fait est que cherchent-ils
manuel valls 1 en attaque ans comme sont
régulièrement
mark est un peu difficile pour lui en ce
moment donc visiblement il a besoin de
la france mise sur une stratégie de
communication
seule chose c'est que le registre de
l'insultent est d'abord une insulte à la
pensée bon donc s'il ya des faits qu'on
vient de nous les montrer
moi je suis désolé mais je me sens très
au clair sur ces questions là et donc je
sois sur les propos qui ont été tenus ou
pas oui bien sûr mais en même temps vous
savez le débat politique qui vu je
préfère qu'il se passe dans la vie
politique et pas devant les tribunaux a
bien déjà annoncées
l'an dernier je crois quand il une
posture bien sûr d'être la république il
avait eu de suite non non il n'y a pas
eu de suite mais ça voilà mais je pense
que la question est d'abord politique et
aux journalistes aussi à faire le
travail
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière pourquoi pourquoi nous
traiter c'est quoi cet item il est sur
quel fondement qu'elle fait voilà c'est
nous qui protégeront lafarge qui donne
de l'argent à des chenaux c'est nous qui
sommes amis avec des terroristes non bon
alors oui le problème c'est quoi cette
histoire a clos le débat en tout cas
c'est un coup d'avoir été notre un genre
en y aura évidemment avec les prochains
invités merci à qui bonne semaine
cha cha
[Musique]